there a moment you'd be like would you
call him no he would let me
let me i i and this is and let's let's
let's talk about reality
okay let's go all right this is not show
business because this is a reality this
could happen this guy could be sitting
right now listening and they're like
damn there's only one way
you got that lingerie
from the bottom of my heart you can
get your juices sucked out by my
girlfriend
via your penis right i don't know why i
just said that yeah
where else would i get nervous because i
think i think this eyeball
i'll suck his ass juice
i would babe take a look at this you
feel like you don't think i can kill it
killian murphy all right just look at
him
yeah killian oh i didn't know what it
was like
yeah yeah i got a little uh
honestly killing you can have sex with
my girlfriend you can have um
do whatever you want with her and i
there's not going to be an
ounce of jealousy or anger
or anything but because that gives me we
get it
but that gives me a free pass yeah but
your free pass is going to be like
julie at cvs down the street you know
what i mean
you know what i mean why do you think no
i'm not a high brown
you know he has a woman at walgreens in
the old walgreens on western see i knew
it i knew it was something like that
who is in love with you she's 90 babe
i know but you know oh yeah come on
that's that's actually very here's my
thing
that's messed up of you um if i were to
talk about hall passes
um it would never be with someone
like because it burst the fantasy like
one of my he met one of my hall passes
and after they became friends i was like
the fantasy is gone like i don't
i don't want their time good
[Laughter]
i think i could i think i could work
with them and i think i can have
developer friendships yeah and you said
it
who's that uh he's going to be the new
blade oh wow you want to go that with it
you want to go dark dark i love my
hershey
so he's old too but again but again
if oh if you befriend him it's over this
would be i don't want him
bobby bobby has a problem with this he
would just oh i have no what are you
talking about
yeah i won't look at the picture but i
don't have a problem
[Laughter]
i think his dick has a wikipedia
have you been watching the olympics at
all no dude i can't get into it why
i just i don't know i think it's because
of uh covet and everything and just
because
it just feels different it don't feel i
don't feel this like a
need to be like you know just america
and all that and